la maison de la culture sera terminée
dans un mois le 15 décembre mais déjà
vous avez lancé une campagne d'adhésion
de ville 2 octobre et je voudrais vous
demander monsieur philippe ii voici
quels sont les premiers résultats que
vous avez pu enregistrer et bien les
premiers résultats sont assez
sympathiques nous avons un adhérent
actuellement toutes les 3 minutes et
déjà plusieurs milliers d'adhésions dont
je crois que c'est un premier bilan
assez satisfaisant
vous attendez certainement d'autres
adhésions et je pense que il y à
quelques hésitations pour certaines
personnes qui trouvent peut-être votre
système d'adhésion et que complexe oui
cet art proches qui nous a été fait mais
enfin je crois qu'on ne s'engage pas
dans une maison de culture comme on va à
la pêche nous ne sommes pas un discret
mais nous cherchons à bien faire
réfléchir les gens c'est on nous leur
demandons un acte de réflexion il
s'engage pour la maison de la culture et
il faut accepter de donner une photo et
quelques petites précisions qui ne sont
d'ailleurs pas du tout un discret ce qui
a pu surprendre si c'est l'époque à
laquelle vous avez lancé cette campagne
d'adhésions donc avec plusieurs mois
d'avancé mais je crois qu'il ya une
explication et là encore on peut parler
d'urgence il ne faut pas attendre le
dernier moment pour adhérer il ne faut
pas attendre le dernier moment il ya un
décalage il ne faudrait pas que le jour
qui est d'ailleurs proche maintenant
puisqu'il s'agit du 4 décembre nous
allons lancer les locations qu'un grand
nombre de personnes se disent bat
maintenant pour aller voir béja adhérons
parce que ça nous posera un problème
administratif réel sérieux alors
l'adhésion on est dedans
inaki ac a adhéré tout de suite pour
adhérer il faut rappeler une adresse et
un numéro de téléphone qui sont
indispensables
et bien pour adhérer on s'adresse au 44
rue marcel perito et pour les
collectivités si elles ont besoin d'un
renseignement elles peuvent téléphoner
au 87 79 76 à saint-etienne la place des
ursules l'a complètement changé d'aspect
depuis le début des travaux du parking
souterrain
la réalisation du gros oeuvre est
actuellement dans sa phase active
c'est ce qu'ont pu constater ce matin
les représentants de la municipalité
stéphanoise le parking une fois terminée
accueillera un millier de voitures une
galerie marchande est prévue avec
garderie d'enfants
les forains n'ont pas été oubliés et un
emplacement leur sera même réservé